Je viens de faire l'amour je suis sur le point de manger des nachos
c'est le plus beau moment de ma vie
ne vous rencontrez pas père est mon cousin
Chantry
merci d'avoir été si aimable dans la
victoire je vais vous donner mon numéro on
devrait sortir ouais  mon copain
va s'inquiéter de ce qui m'est arrivé
alors les amis ouais pourquoi pas hey Frank
si l'amour des contes de fées t'inspire à être
noble et courageux mais dans la vraie vie l'
amour n'est qu'une excuse passe-
partout à Vegas je ne sais pas si tu
sont en fait cyniques ou juste être
une boule de fromage romantique super folle alors Wallace nous
avons parlé des problèmes complexes de notre
temps les hommes et les femmes peuvent-ils vraiment être amis
ou voulez-vous secrètement frapper Chantry
elle a une gamme de voix et des murs ici salut
qui vient par êtes-vous  essayer de coucher
avec ma copine ne facture pas
je ne m'inquiéterais pas nous parlons juste mec d'accord
vous ne pouvez pas interagir avec la femme
sans sexe tout [ __ ] en l'air mais je peux
parce que je suis un adulte et  c'est tellement
adorable que tu crois vraiment que
désolé tu '  Je ne vais pas bien alors Wallace mec
nous sommes amis J'ai déjà appelé Dibs sur
lui
Dalia tu le connais à peine Je voudrais
essayer cette robe c'est une taille - es-tu
- je suis une dent wow je suis ici patron
d'accord monsieur vos yeux fermés oui
vous d'accord je ne suis sûr de rien on
m'a proposé un emploi à Taiwan je serai
bientôt parti
c'est très facile d'être cynique à propos du déjeuner
jusqu'à ce que vous ayez eu cette connexion instantanée
si vous êtes  heureusement que ça arrive une fois dans la
vie
100% l'honnêteté est le fondement de toute
relation eh bien vous êtes sous cadeaux
avec Nicole oui tout oui ce que vous
tous en 2006 était son nom euh bébé euh ouais
elle ne ressemblait pas à une femme pour être juste
quatre-vingt-dix  - neuf pour cent d'honnêteté est le
fondement de toute relation